el diputado oficialista jorge rodríguez
fue ratificado como el presidente de la
asamblea legislativa de venezuela para
el periodo 2022 2023 al recibir el voto
favorable de una amplia mayoría de la
cámara en la que el 92% de los escaños
corresponden a los legisladores
chavistas y el resto están ocupados por
opositores por el momento se desconoce
el número exacto de apoyos que obtuvo
rodríguez ya que la votación se realizó
a mano alzada y no se hizo un cómputo
preciso al quedar claro a primera vista
que una abrumadora mayoría apostó por su
continuidad al frente del legislativo
después de que los oficialistas se
hicieran nuevamente con la directiva de
la asamblea nacional el diputado
opositor josé gregorio correa aseguró
antes de concluir la sesión que los
chavistas son mayoría en el hemiciclo
del parlamento pero no en las calles de
venezuela fueron 700.000 votos que no
ingresaron de la misma manera y se le
tuvieron que descontar porque sacaron
menos
con lo cual
tiene que ser significativo
eso tiene que llamar la atención siguen
siendo la mayoría de la cámara pero no
la mayoría de la calle el bloque
opositor considerado disidente del
antichavismo mayoritario presentó una
propuesta para la junta directiva de la
asamblea con el diputado luís augusto
romero como presidente sin embargo esta
sugerencia no pasó la prueba al no
contar con suficientes votos al solo ser
20 diputados anti chavistas en la cámara